[संगीत]
हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग दोस्तों
एक बार बता दीजिए सबको
कंफर्म कर दीजिए सबको मेरी आवाज सुने दे
रही है नहीं दे रही
ओके थैंक यू तो फिर से आप सभी का स्वागत
हमारे युटुब चैनल पर
जो लास्ट क्लास में हमने पढ़ा था सबको पता
है और इससे जो हमारा टॉपिक चल रहा है
टेलिजेंस के बड़े में तो आज उसको हम
कंटिन्यू करते हैं और आप सभी को पता है
इंटेलिजेंस क्या होता है ऐसे परफॉर्म करना
है और आपको मैंने बताया था की ट्विटर पर
इंटेलिजेंस आपका फॉर्म कर रहे क्योंकि
ट्विटर है क्या की एक मोस्ट
फेमस प्लेटफॉर्म है और मैंने बताया था की
अगर आप जब ट्विटर के ऊपर ऊपर से
इंटेलिजेंस परफॉर्म करोगे
सॉरी सॉरी टेक्निकल मैथर्ड हम जो क्या
करते हैकर्स मेथड भी बोल सकते हैं और नॉन
टेक्निकल मेथड उसको हम ट्रेडिशनल मेथड भी
बोलते हैं और जो कल लास्ट क्लास में हमने
जो शिखा था की जो था आपका कौन सा रेडिसन
मेथड ट्रेडिशनल मेथड की हेल्प से हम कैसे
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग करते हैं ये मैंने आपको
कल लास्ट क्लास में बताया था अगर कुछ लोग
आज ही आए हैं डायरेक्टली तो प्लीज आज की
क्लास के बाद आप डायरेक्टली आपको क्या
करना है कल की क्लास को भी आपको देखना है
उसके बेसिस पे ही आपको ज्यादा इंटरेस्ट
आएगा पता क्या है की जब तक आप नॉन
टेक्निकल मेथड का उसे नहीं करोगे तब तक आप
क्या है की टेक्निकल मेथड उसे करने में
काफी कंफर्टेबल फूल नहीं करोगे क्योंकि
आपके पास इनफॉरमेशन नहीं होगी आपके टारगेट
के बड़े में अगर आप क्या कर सकते हो तो
सबसे पहले आपने टेक्निक नॉन टेक्निकल मेथड
को एड ट्रेडिशनल मेथड को एक एक्टर के साथ
अगर आपका फॉर्म कर पाते हो तो आप क्या की
आप अपने टेक्निकल मेथड को काफी अच्छे से
काफी बेहतरीन तरीके से परफॉर्म कर पाओगे
तो अब बात करते हैं की आज हम इसके बाद
करने वाले हैं
और टेक्निकल मेथड की हेल्प से हम कैसे ए
परफॉर्म करने वाले हैं अपना ट्विटर ओपन
100 से इंटेलिजेंस
चलते हैं प्रैक्टिकल है हमारा
एक दिन का टाइम दीजिए मुझे जस्ट मिनट आई
बिल टेक मी नोट्स और ओपन मी मशीन
चलो सभी को पता है की लास्ट क्लास में मार
टारगेट किया था लास्ट क्लास में जो मार
टारगेट था वह था हमारा ये आपका पेटीएम
पेटीएम हमारा टारगेट था और पेटीएम के बड़े
में कुछ इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग हमने की थी वो
कौन सी इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग है जैसे की हम
अगर ओपन करते हैं तो ये था अभी हमने क्या
किया आज जो टारगेट पेटीएम था और जो भी
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग के लिए अगर आप लोगों ने
किसी ने मुझे ज्यादा इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग की
हो तो आप बता सकते हो मुझे चाट में
एडरवाइज रहने दीजिए क्योंकि मैंने जो आपके
सामने जो लाइव में इनफॉरमेशन कहते ने की
थी की जो पेटीएम है उसका यूजर नाम क्या था
आते डी रेट पेटीएम था और उसके फाउंडर का
नाम था विजय शेखर शर्मा विजय शेखर शर्मा
और उसका जो क्या था एक सीईओ बी है पेटीएम
कंपनी के और हमने अबाउट देखा था उसके
अबाउट करके देखा था उसके बड़े में आप
इनफॉरमेशन गैलरी की थी और उसकी जो आईडी
एक्टिवा आईडी है वो
@शेखर है और जो क ओ है जो सीपीयू और
पेटीएम का वो क्या है
है और कुछ अदर डोमिनेंस भी हमने देखें थे
पेटीएम केयर पेटीएम मनी पेटीएम पेमेंट
बैंक्स पेटीएम
सभी की हमने क्या की थी तो उसकी जो आईडी
थी क्या नाम है
उनकी जो ट्विटर आईडी है वो सब की @ पेटीएम
करियर है
@ पेटीएम मनी है और एवं जो हम पेटीएम बनी
है उसकी सीईओ है वरुण श्रीधर उसके बड़े
में भी हम इनफॉरमेशन निकाल पे कल
@ पेटीएम बैंक है @ पेटीएम बिजनेस है ये
साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग हम कर पे
तो कोई भी टारगेट ले सकते थे ब्रो
प्रेक्टिस के लिए कोई भी टारगेट ले सकते
थे
तो अब बात करते हैं की हम कंटिन्यू करते
हैं तो हमारे पास इतनी इनफॉरमेशन और हमने
क्या है इंडिविजुअल टारगेट परफॉर्म करने
की कोशिश की थी अब इंडिविजुअल टारगेट क्या
थी जो हमारा क्या था एक बार हम जाते हैं
आते डी रेट और हमने डिजिटल टारगेट किया था
विजय एक और
विजय शेखर और
हमने क्या किया था इंडिविजुअल टारगेट
परफॉर्म किया था और मैंने आपको बताया था
की आपको कुछ भी चीजों को छोड़ना नहीं है
हर एक चीज को आपको क्या है नोटिस करना है
हर एक चीज पे आपको देखना है तो देखिए अब
क्या की अभी शायद ये 16 जुलाई की पोस्ट है
और क्या है लाइव स्ट्रीमिंग के ऊपर कुछ
इन्होंने क्या है शायद कमेंट भी किया हुआ
वॅटीवर तो आपका कैसा ओपन करके देख सकते हो
मी पेटीएम बैंक अकाउंट हस ब्लॉक्ड ओके ये
साड़ी चीज हैं आपको क्या करना है नोटिस
करके देखना है तो यहां पर क्या है आप देख
सकते हो की लेटेस्ट पोस्ट कौन सी इन्होंने
परफॉर्म किया हुए हैं
लेटेस्ट पोस्ट है
पी पाल
तो ये साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन थी तो अभी देखो हम
क्या ज्यादा कुछ खास लिंक परफॉर्म करनी
पाएं एक दूसरे के साथ किसी और दूसरे के
साथ तो अब बात करते हैं देखो हमारे पास
क्या है विजय सेठ विजय शेखर अब एक चीज
बताइए आप लोगों को जो विजय शर्मा है इसमें
से सर नाम क्या हो सकता है
इसमें से सरनेम क्या हो सकता है मुझे
बताइए
इसमें सरनेम क्या हो सकता है बताइए
तो की हम स्टार्ट करते हैं देखो सबसे पहले
जो ट्रिक है जो हम बात करने वाले हैं आज
से स्टार्ट करने वाले जो टेक्निकल मैथर्ड
है आपका जो इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग का ट्विटर
के ऊपर उसमें सबसे पहले जो ट्रिक हैं
जिसका हम उसे करने वाले हैं उसको हम उसको
बोलते हैं हम स्लिक्स जिसको हम बोलेंगे
स्ट्रीक्स देखिए s6 मतलब स्टार और सबसे
पहले आप पढ़ चुके हो उसके बड़े में तार का
मतलब क्या होता है आप सबको पहले से ही पता
है की एनीथिंग अन्य थिंक एनीथिंग
होता है ये सबको आपको पता है क्योंकि जब
भी मैंने आपको नेक्स्ट पटाया था तो वहां
पे मैंने बताया था स्टार का मतलब क्या
होता है और ये क्या है की ये प्रोग्रामिंग
लैंग्वेज का पार्ट है तो ये हर जगह उसे
में आता है और हर जगह आप इसको उसे कर सकते
हो क्योंकि हर एक प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज
इसको उसे करती है क्योंकि प्रोग्राम में
लैंग्वेज का ये एक पार्ट है इसलिए काफी
पावरफुल भी है और ये कैसे पॉपुलर
दिखता हूं पर एग्जांपल मुझे क्या करना है
मैं मैंने क्या किया
हमारा जो टारगेट था विजय वे आई जे ए ए
पास विजय शेखर है विजय शेखर
विजय शेखर विजय शेखर
उसके बाद मैंने क्या कर दिया टॉप परफॉर्म
कर दिया उसके बाद मैंने क्या किया तार लगा
दिया ये मैं चाहता हूं की अब विजय शेखर के
नाम से जितने भी ट्विटर हैंडल्स हैं वो
सारे क्योंकि फ्रंट में क्या होना चाहिए
विजय शेखर होना चाहिए उसके बाद कुछ भी हो
सकता है वो सारे साइड वेटर हैंडल को क्या
करेगा ये आपके सामने रिजल्ट में शो कर
देगा अब देखिए यहां पर आपको देखने को मिल
जाएंगे विजय शेखर शर्मा विजय शेखर गुप्ता
बीजेपी और वोट का इनफॉरमेशन
[संगीत]
श्रीनिवास गंदा उसके बाद यह था
विजय शेखर विजय शेखर विजय शेखर जहां और
विजय शेखर ऑलवेज स्कूल
है आपको देखने को मिलता है
अभी ये हमारे कैसे में कैसे पावरफुल हो
सकता है देखो अभी क्या किया हमने
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग की और हमने क्या किया
पता किया ये सीईओ है ये सीपीयू है या उन
हमारे पास कुछ और भी इनफॉरमेशन है ये
रिलेटिव हो सकते हैं ये फ्रेंड्स हो सकते
हैं तो अब हम क्या है की हम यहां तक तो
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग के स्टेप में रुकेंगे
नहीं हम यहां तक तो इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग के
स्टेप में रुकेंगे नहीं तो
तो हमें क्या करना होगा हमें क्या करना
पड़ेगा की हम उसके रिलेटिव्स एवं उसके
फैमिली मेंबर्स उनके नेटिव रिलेटिव्स भाई
वाइस सिस्टर व्हाट हैव हमें जो इनफॉरमेशन
मिलेगी वो हम फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश
करेंगे अगर वो इनफॉरमेशन हमें फाइंड आउट
करनी होगी तो हमें सबको पता है ठीक है की
जो सी आई ओ है ये इस कंपनी के ये काफी
अवेयरन होंगे साइबर सिक्योरिटी के बड़े
में या सिक्योरिटी और उसके बड़े में इनको
पता होगा बट व्हाट अबाउट यू डियर फैमिली
मेंबर्स फैमिली मेंबर नहीं होंगे ना और
ऊपर से क्या की वो तो होंगे नहीं उनको
बताया भी होगा तो इतना कोई फॉलो करता नहीं
तो अब बात करते हैं की आप सबको पता है की
अगर आपके पास किसी भी टारगेट का अगर
यूजरनेम है और उसका सरनेम है आपके पास
टारगेट का एक प्रकाश नाम है तो आप क्या कर
सकते हो ये आपको सबको पता है की हर कोई
फैमिली मेंबर्स आप पर रिलेटिव रिलेटिव एवं
आपके यहां पर आप रहते हो आपके सराउंडिंग्स
एरिया में
तो क्योंकि जहां पर रहते हो आप लोग करते
होंगे तो वहां पर क्या है की वो उसे सरनेम
के साथ आईडी क्रिएट करते ही करते होंगे
तो आपके फैमिली मेंबर्स हो सकता है
क्योंकि वाइफ है इनके भाई हैं इनके बहन है
इनके फादर
बेबी अगर वो ट्विटर हैंडल ऑपरेट कर रहे
होंगे ट्विटर अगर चलते भी होंगे तो क्या
कर रहे होंगे वो लास्ट में इनका सर नाम
पक्का उसे कर देंगे तो आप हमारे पास क्या
है हम क्या कर सकते हैं अब इसके बेसिस पे
हम अपना एनालिसिस स्टार्ट करते हैं तो हम
क्या करेंगे स्टार एनीथिंग बट लास्ट में
क्या होना चाहिए थर्मो होना चाहिए एस हा ए
आर एम ए धर्म लास्ट में क्या होना चाहिए
शर्मा एस हा ए आर एम ए अब मैं इसको कर
देता हूं अभी ये क्या ए गया जिसका भी
सरनेम शर्मा है सबको क्या करेगा ये शो कर
देगा आपके रिजल्ट के सामने एनीथिंग आगे
कुछ भी हो सकता है लेकिन लास्ट में देखो
अनुष्का शर्मा लाइक डेट कपिल शर्मा और यह
है रोहित शर्मा
से शर्मा
लाइक डेट डॉक्टर दिनेश ले इतनी साड़ी
इनफॉरमेशन देखो साड़ी देखने को मिलेगा अब
आपको नहीं पता की कौन से अप हरे को आपको
क्या करना पड़ेगा प्रोफाइल को जो आपको शक
होता है उसको क्या करना ओपन करके देखना ही
होगा आपको पता करने को उसका क्या वो
रिलेटिव हैं मदर हैं फादर हैं रोहित शर्मा
से रिलेटेड काफी है तो देखो एडिटर इन के
और अध्यक्ष इंडिया टीवी ओके हम बात करते
हैं अभी हम और भी और भी आगे चलते हैं तभी
तो हमें खुद इसे पी के आर एस अल्फाबेटिकल
उसे किया हुआ है अभी हम बात करते हैं जो
हमें अगर वापस से बैग जाते हैं की विजय
शेखर शर्मा
कर सकते हैं की हम वह चीज गैस कर सकते हैं
तो इसलिए ट्रिक है आपकी स्टार का उसे करके
एक स्टार का उसे करके आप क्या कर सकते हो
उनके फैमिली मेंबर्स को इनग्रेगेटिव
गैस कर सकते हैं गैस करने के लिए आपको
क्या करना है अभी यहां पर क्या है की
शरमास इतनी ज्यादा इनफॉरमेशन आपको देखने
को मिलेगी क्योंकि अभी आपके पास इतनी
अमाउंट इनफॉरमेशन नहीं है की आप इन चीजों
को गैस कर पाते क्योंकि आपने जो ट्रेडिशनल
मेथड का उसे करके जो इनफॉरमेशन के अंदर की
है मैंने लास्ट क्लास में
0.1% इनफॉरमेशन पैदल किया उसके बेसिस पे
हम फैमिली मेंबर्स से पूछना थोड़ा सा
टिपिकल पार्ट है तो ये मैंने क्या आपको
ट्रिक बताऊंगा क्योंकि मैं इतनी इनफॉरमेशन
कैसे करके दिखाऊं तो फिर पूरा ट्विटर और
मेरा क्या है एक से दो महीने हो जाएगा वो
मैं करके परफॉर्म करके करने वाला नहीं मैं
आपको सिर्फ ट्रिक बताऊंगा तो एक ये ट्रिक
है की इस ट्रिक का उसे करके आप किसी भी के
शब्द के बेसिस पे आप क्या कर सकते हो
फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश करते हो उनके
रिलेटिव फैमिली मेंबर डेट इसे तो एक तो
ट्रिक आपकी ये थी ट्रिक नंबर वन जो हमने
अगर मैं आपको का रहा था यहां पे लिख देता
हूं ये है आपके ट्रिक नंबर वन
सबसे पहले ट्रिक थी ये
ये नंबर वन उसके बाद उसके बाद हम बात करते
हैं एक नंबर तू की जो ट्रिक है
हम उसे करते हैं वो कौन सी होती है उसके
बाद करते हैं अभी जो ट्रिक है आपकी
एक ट्रिक आई है आपकी पर एग्जांपल आपने
क्या किया देखो मैं साड़ी की साड़ी ट्रिक
कहना आपको एक एग्जांपल स्पेसिफिक लेकर
जाऊंगा मैं डायरेक्टली ट्रिक का नाम बता
सकता हूं लेकिन बट क्या है की मैं आपको
डायरेक्ट का नाम ये बताना है देखो क्या है
की आपने क्या किया इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग कर
देते हैं ट्रेडीशन मेथड का उसे करते हैं
या आपको पता है आपको कुछ एक ऐसा आइडिया है
यह आपको पता है की किसी स्पेसिफिक मठ में
या स्पेसिफिक एयर में जिसको भी आपने
टारगेट किया है अगर एवं कंपनी है या एवं
को यूजर नाम है जिसको भी आपने टारगेट किया
है की वो किसी स्पेसिफिक मठ में या
स्पेसिफिक टाइम में स्पेसिफिक एयर में
उन्होंने क्या किया है की कुछ
ट्वीट किया है कुछ पोस्ट किया है या किसी
चीज के बड़े में जिक्र किया है जहां पर
क्या है कहानी ना कहानी उन्होंने क्या
किया है उसे चीज को अटेंड किया है लाइक
किया है ट्वीट किया है मतलब आपको थोड़ा सा
आइडिया इनफॉरमेशन गदर की हेल्प से कई बार
आया आपने न्यूज़ में देखा होगा कहानी भी
देखा आपको लगता है ऐसा कुछ तो आप
स्पेसिफिक मठ और स्पेसिफिक एयर के बेसिस
पे क्या कर सकते हो वो इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग
कर सकते हो आप लेकिन उसके लिए आपके पास
थोड़ी बहुत प्रीवियसली क्या करना है आपको
ये आइडिया लगाना पड़ेगा की हां की मैं जो
भी सर्च करने वाला हूं तो भी मैं सच करने
वाला हूं वो क्या है लेकिन एक चीज ध्यान
में रखना
इनफॉरमेशन
गैलरी में पता लगाया की हां यह कीवर्ड्स
ऐसा है हो सकता है की इस टाइम पर भी इसका
कुछ जिक्र हुआ है इसलिए कोई इवेंट क्रिएट
हुआ होगा है इस पर इन्होंने आज इतने टाइम
पर जिक्र किया इससे पहले भी हुआ होगा तो
इस तरीके से तो आपके पास क्या है की इस
ट्रिक को उसे करने से आपको कीवर्ड्स
हैशटैग तो होने ही चाहिए आपके पास यूजरनेम
नहीं है तो यूजरनेम आप इनके बेसिस पे
निकाल सकते हो तो उसे ट्रिक का नाम क्या
है उसको हम उसे करते हैं लिस्ट लिस्ट के
बाद दिया गया है कोलोन उसे करते हैं उसके
बाद विदाउट स्पेस हम क्या करते हैं वो
यहां पे स्पेसिफाई करेंगे हम या तो हम
मेंशन कर देंगे एमटीएस मठ में मेंशन कर
देंगे मठ जो भी मठ सही है या हम यहां पे
मेंशन कर देंगे
मेंशन कर देंगे ये जी भी एयर की हम वो
इनफॉरमेशन देखना चाहते हैं तो कैसे हम
आपको ट्रिक परफॉर्म करके दिखता हूं पर
एग्जांपल मेरे पास कोई के शब्द है पेटीएम
मेरे पास क्या है
पेटीएम पेटीएम है उसके बाद मैं क्या करना
चाहता हूं लिस्ट करना चाहता हूं ऊपर से
क्या मेरे पास फूल या पैटर्न के साथ
पेटीएम और @ पेटीएम उसे कर रहा हूं मैं
पेटीएम लिस्ट करना चाहता हूं और मैं कौन
सा मां मार्च और
2022 2022 अब यहां पर 2022 में इस जी
ट्वीट में या जी जी ट्वीट में
@ पेटीएम यूजरनेम का उसे किया गया होगा जी
जी ने अपने ट्वीट में इसको मेंशन किया
देखो यहां पर कोई भी ऐसी कोई पोस्ट नहीं
देखने को मिल रही अब आप बात कर रहे हो
लेटेस्ट लेटेस्ट
यहां पे क्या की बस यही इनफॉरमेशन आपको
देखने को मिल रही है पेटीएम एंटरटेनमेंट
लिस्ट अब मैं बात करता हूं चलो ठीक है मैं
एक कम कर देता हूं ये हटा देता हूं मैं
@ हटा देता हूं रिमूव कर देता हूं ये
देखिए अभी कुछ देखने को मिल रहा है
लेटेस्ट पोस्ट पेटीएम मॉल नो मतलब ये केवल
2002 में उसे नहीं है मतलब मार्च में नहीं
है अब मैं क्या कर रहा हूं की मेरे पास
मार्च है अभी मैं क्या कर रहा हूं मार्च
के बाद मैंने क्या कर दिया क्योंकि मार्च
और ये दोनों में स्पेसिफाई कर दिया मैंने
अभी मैं बात कर रहा हूं पर एग्जांपल मैं
बात कर रहा हूं
जनवरी इस तरीके से क्या कर सकते हो आप
अपने ट्रिक को मेंशन करने की कोशिश कर
सकते हो जनवरी
की
जेएनयू आर्य
मतलब कुछ है
यहां पर 23 कर देते हैं
तो इस तरीके से क्या कर सकते हो आप लिस्ट
कर सकते हो अपने किसी भी बेसिस पर
अपने एयर के बेसिस पर और क्या है इसके
बेसिस पर आप मठ के बेसिस पे इस तरीके से
इस चीज को आप उसे कर सकते हो अब देखो क्या
है की यहां पर जल्दी इसलिए नहीं आए
क्योंकि हमारे पास इतनी ज्यादा इनफॉरमेशन
गैदरिंग हमने की नहीं है क्योंकि एक
स्पेसिफिक इनफॉरमेशन
कहते हैं हमारे पास टाइम नहीं था लास्ट
क्लास हमारे पास ओन्ली वन हावर था और उसके
बाद क्या किया आपके लिए इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग
करके लेट आऊंगा तो दिस इसे नोट गुड पर यू
और गुड नोट डी गुड पर ए टीचर तो अब बात
करते हैं नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट ट्रिक की बात
करते हैं एक नंबर तू हो गया हमारे पास इस
ट्रिक को आप ऐसे उसे कर सकते हैं क्योंकि
ये काफी हेल्पफुल साबित हो शक्ति है आपके
इनफॉरमेशन में क्योंकि आपके पास क्या है
की एक पीरियड है एक टाइम के दौरान
पोस्ट कमेंट पर जा सकते हो उसे टाइम के
दौरान और जहां पर क्या की आपको ज्यादा
एक्यूरेट रिजल्ट मिलेंगे रैंडम रिजल्ट की
बजे अब बात करते हैं अगर थर्ड जो ट्रिक
होती है उसके बड़े में बात करते हैं जो
कौन सी है थर्ड की
हैशटैग वाली देखो सभी को जो ट्रिक नंबर
थ्री आई है ट्रिक 03 है जो है जिसको जो आई
है जिसको हम बोलते हैं हैशटैग
हैशटैग इसको बोलते हैं
कोई भी केवल
नेक्स्ट सभी लगभग सभी सोशल मीडिया
प्लेटफॉर्म में क्या करता है एक्जिस्ट
करता है चाहे वो आपका फेसबुक इंस्टाग्राम
हो ट्विटर हो या लिख लेना सभी में हैशटैग
क्या करता है
राहत ही राहत है अब देखो लोग हैशटैग को
उसे करते हैं कुछ चीजों को मेंशन करने के
लिए किसी स्पेसिफिक टॉपिक पर बात करने के
लिए किसी इवेंट पर किसी हॉट इशू पर एक
दूसरे से बात करने के लिए एक दूसरे को
अवेयर करने के लिए एक दूसरे को बताने के
लिए क्या करते हैं लोग हैशटैग का उसे करते
हैं और यह हैशटैग जो है यह हैकर्स के लिए
काफी इंपॉर्टेंट साबित है और हैकर्स के
लिए तो काफी इंपॉर्टेंट इनफॉरमेशन आपको
प्रोवाइड कर देता है क्योंकि आपको पता है
की जब आपने इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग कर रहे हो
तो आपको आपके सामने कुछ ना कुछ तो हैशटैग
ऐसे आए होंगे जो आपके
रख लिए होंगे अपनी नोटबुक के अंदर या
नोट्स के अंदर तो आप क्या करोगे उसे
स्पेसिफिक हैशटैग के बेसिस पर क्या कर
सकते हो आप इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग कर सकते हो
पर एग्जांपल मैंने क्या है की जब मैं क्या
कर रहा था की जब मैं इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग कर
रहा था जो मेरे सीईओ हैं इसके पेटीएम के
जो विजय शेखर शर्मा है मैं जो मजे क्या
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग करते वक्त मुझे क्या
करना है कुछ ट्वीट्स ऐसे देखें की उनको
किसी चीज में इंटरेस्ट है पर एग्जांपल
उनको किसी फुटबॉल मैच में टेस्ट है फुटबॉल
टीम में क्या करता है वो इंटरेस्ट दिखाई
हैं फुटबॉल टीम के साथ मतलब वेट करते हो
से रिलेटेड फुटबॉल से रिलेटेड तो अभी क्या
है की और वो क्या करते हैं हैशटैग का उसे
करते हैं हैशटैग हैशटैग फुटबॉल तो अभी भी
क्या की मैं उसे इंटरेस्ट को कैसे कंफर्म
करूंगा मगर कंफर्म कैसे करूंगा की मैं जब
वो हैशटैग के बेसिस पर मैं क्या करता हूं
सर परफॉर्म करूंगा तो मुझे अगर वो उसका
ज्यादा इंटरेस्ट होगा उनका अगर उसे
पर्टिकुलर परसों का या पर्टिकुलर जो जिसको
आपने टारगेट किया गया उसे टारगेट का उसे
चीज में इंटरेस्ट होगा या उसे चीज को
ट्वीट करता होगा तो इसका मतलब रेगुलरली
करता ही होगा क्योंकि उसका इंटरेस्ट है या
उसको अच्छा लगता है या वो कंट्रोल भी करता
हूं लेकिन कुछ ना ट्वीट करता है तो उसके
बेसिस पर क्या कर रहे हो तो रिकंफ कर सकते
हो वेरीफाई कर सकते हो क्या मैं जो चीज को
कर रहा हूं की जी चीज को जो आपका टारगेट
ट्वीट कर रहा है जिसके ऊपर क्या मैं सच
में उसने कितने ऐसे हेड पर्टिकुलर जो
पोस्ट है इसकी जो पर्टिकुलर हैशटैग की
पोस्ट पर कितनी पोस्ट पूछने क्या लाइक
कमेंट कुछ किया है तो उससे भी आप आइडिया
लगा लोग आपके पास एक आइडिया मिल जाएगा की
ओके इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग करने में की ओके इस
चीज का ये इंटरेस्ट है तो इस तरीके से भी
आप क्या करें पर एग्जांपल मैं एग्जांपल ले
रहा हूं अब मुझे इसका कोई आइडिया नहीं है
अभी तक मुझे तो मैं क्या किया # फुट बात
यही होगा ना हां फुटबॉल अब ये क्या है
ओनली पर्टिकुलर हैशटैग फुटबॉल के बेसिस पर
जितने भी जितने पोस्ट होंगे सभी को यहां
पर क्या कर दिया ये यहां पर शो कर देगा
टॉप पे जाता हूं यहां पर टॉप के लिए देखा
हूं
तो फिर क्या देखने को मिल रही है बिग फाइट
जो भी आपको इनफॉरमेशन
रेट विच को पढ़ोगे कमेंट्स को लाइक्स को
देखोगे तो आपको यहां से इनफॉरमेशन मिल
सकते हैं क्या जो आपका जो टारगेट है क्या
वो इस चीज में इंटरेस्ट सच में रखना है या
वैसे उसने रैंडम कभी कर दिया था तो इस
तरीके से आप क्या कर सकते हो हैशटैग के
बेसिस पे भी इनफॉरमेशन निकाल सकते हैं और
हैशटैग में क्या कर सकते हैं हम किसको
मेरे पास है और मैं क्या कर सकता हूं पर
एग्जांपल मैंने यहां पे लिस्ट किया अब मैं
उसको कंबाइंडली भी उसे कर सकता हूं लिस्ट
किया मैंने और मैं क्या करता हूं की आप
अप्रैल
2022 इंटर कर दिया क्या इस टाइम
अप्रैल लिखा मैंने अभी मैं कम करता हूं
मैं कम करता हूं
क्या की 2013
देखो
इस तरीके से आप देख सकते हो
1 मिनट कम करोगे
[संगीत]
हमारे ट्रिक नंबर फोर
04 जो ट्रिक आपकी
वह ट्रैक नंबर
क्या है टारगेट का यूजरनेम है और टारगेट
का फ्रेंड्स का यूजरनेम है टारगेट के
फ्रेंड का हमारे पास क्या है यूजर नाम है
अब दो चीज हमारे पास है अब मैं क्या चाहता
हूं की मैं देखना चाहता हूं की क्या इन
दोनों ने आपस में ट्वीट के थ्रू
कम्युनिकेशन किया है या नहीं है अगर ये
मुझे की देखना चाहता हूं ये मैं कंफर्म
करना चाहता हूं तो इसके लिए भी एक ट्रिक
होती है क्योंकि यह काफी हेल्पफुल हो सकता
है आपके लिए ये काफी हेल्पफुल हो सकता है
कैसे हो सकता है इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग में
क्योंकि देखो आपके पास यूजरनेम और यूजरनेम
है दोनों के लेकिन क्या है की आप इसके
बेसिस पे इस टेक्निक के आधार पर क्या कर
सकते हो आप ये भी पता कर सकते हो की यह
किस स्पेसिफिक टॉपिक पर बात कर रहे थे जो
हो सकता है की आगे ए हैकर या कोई भी
हैकिंग सिनेरियो क्रिएट करने के लिए आपके
लिए हेल्पफुल हो या फरदर इनफॉरमेशन
गैदरिंग में आपके लिए हेल्पफुल हो आपकी
मदद करें
तो हम कैसे कर सकते हैं तो हम कर सकते हैं
फ्रॉम एक फ्रॉम होता है फ्रॉम में हम क्या
करते हैं फ्रॉम में डालते हैं यूजर नाम $1
स्पेस उसके बाद तू मतलब
ये क्या करेगा तू मतलब क्या है की यूजरनेम
वन से यूजर नंबर तू को जितने भी क्या किया
ट्वीट्स की गई है जो भी कुछ लिया गया है
इनके बीच में जो भी है उसको यह शो है और
जी नंबर वन से लेकर यूजर नाम तू के बीच
में जो भी कम्युनिकेशन होगा ट्वीट के थ्रू
ये क्या करेगा लिस्ट आउट कर देगा इस में
इसके बाद इसके बाद हम कैसे कर सकते हैं
मैं इसको इसको ऐसे भी उसे कर सकता हूं मैं
फ्रॉम
यूजर नाम तू तू
यूजरनेम वन तू
चेक कर सकता हूं
एक और तरीका मैं क्या कर सकता हूं फ्रॉम
मैं क्या का सकता हूं फ्रॉम मैं बोल रहा
हूं की स्टार मतलब वो साड़ी की साड़ी
ट्वीट देखनी है और जो की गई होगी किसको तू
यूजर नाम यूजरनेम वन को की गई हो ये भी मत
देख सकता हूं यूजर नाम वन तू कितनी हाइट
ज्यादा है यूजर नाम वन वन को क्या किया है
मैं आपको वन देखने को मिलेगा वो मैं फाइंड
आउट कर सकता हूं एवं मैं क्या कर सकता हूं
या मैं ऐसा कर सकता हूं फ्रॉम क्रोम
वन है उसकी उसकी साड़ी ट्वीट्स को क्या
करना है आपको या पोस्ट को आपको क्या करना
है लिस्ट आउट कर देना है
यहां पर की है तो देखिए अभी इस तरीके से
ट्रिक को आप क्या कर सकते हो उसे कर सकते
हो पर एग्जांपल और भी तरीके इसके तो कैसे
उसे कर सकते मैंने और भी कैसे कर सकते हो
फ्रॉम क्या कर सकते हो फ्रॉम उसके बाद
आपने क्या किया यूजर नाम यूजरनेम और उसके
बाद क्या क्या आपको क्या देखनी है वो साइट
देखनी है ग नाम की निजी नाम वन की देखनी
है लेकिन क्या है साथ में आप क्या शब्द दे
दो की मैं पेटीएम पे का व एटीएम पेटीएम
कीवर्ड साथ में देखना चाहता था की आप सारे
क्या है की यूजर नाम वन से साइट ट्वीट
देखना चाहते हो आप साड़ी पोस्ट देखना
चाहते हैं हो लेकिन उसमें कौन से करना
चाहते हो की पे टी एम तो हम बात करते हैं
चलो प्रैक्टिकल देखते हैं कुछ हम देख
पाएंगे अभी हम मैं क्या करता हूं फ्रॉम
मैंने किया फ्रॉम और जो फ्रॉम मेरा टारगेट
किया था की आते डी रेट विजय
वा
शेखर एस हा
एस
देखते हैं की विजय शेखर
देखो यह साड़ी साड़ी स्टार जितने भी इसके
दो इनके द्वारा की गई होगी पोस्ट है सभी
देखो टुडे हो में ऑफ फर्स्ट डू डू अवर
प्रोफेशनल बर डॉ और रेड लेंस फॉक्स ऑन डी
वर्ल्ड इन डी मिडिल ऑफ डी सॉन्ग ऑफ डी पेन
और सड़नेस तू एवरी रेलवे एम्पलाई और लीडर
हूं इस ग्रंथि देखिए अभी देख सकते हैं
इन्होंने
जून पांच की है तो जो एक इंसिडेंट है
ट्वीट किया हुआ है ओके उसके बाद यहां पर
तो काफी ट्वीट है अभी भर भर के ट्वीट्स है
अब यहां देखिए
ट्वीट किया होगा देखिए यहां पर यहां पर
सभी को इन्होंने क्या किया पोस्ट किया है
जहां ओनली इन्हीं का ही है
चलो काफी कुछ इनफॉरमेशन
ओके मतलब यह क्या है देखो ये इनफॉरमेशन
हमारे साथ हो सकता है
ट्विटर भाई देखो यह रहा
केवल
इंजीनियर
एक दूसरे को क्या करना है आपको इस तरीके
से आप उसे कर सकते हैं देखो मैं आपको
सिर्फ ट्रिक बताऊंगा क्योंकि हर एक चीज
मैं आपको परफॉर्म करूंगा का आईटी बिल टाइम
कंजूमिंग और हमें क्या है काफी दिन तक एक
ही टॉपिक में रहना पद सकता है
दूसरे में क्या दिखाए था आपको एक और ट्रिक
कैसे उसे कर सकते हैं
इस तरीके से आपको क्या है रीडिंग
कैपेबिलिटी हनी चाहिए अब मैं का सकता हूं
एक ट्रिक है यहां पर 2 के अंदर क्या कर
सकते हो की किसी भी यूजर नाम को एड कर
सकते हो जो आप उसमें की गई होगी अब मैं
क्या करता हूं यहां पर अब यहां पे मैंने
क्या किया पेटीएम
उसे कर रहा हूं
या अब ये क्या है 10 एयर बिफोर पेटीएम हेड
है
यहां भी देखो कुछ इनफॉरमेशन
देखने को मिल शक्ति है
अक्टूबर नंबर्स ऑफ यह नवंबर 22 लाइक डेट
अभी मैं इसको ओपन करता हूं यहां पर क्या
देखने को मिलेगा हमें यहां देखने को मिल
सकते हैं 43
इंटरनेशनल बैंक के फेंटेक्स स्कूल
इंस्ट्रक्टर और डी पब्लिश्ड ऑथर ऑफ डी
डिजिटल बैंकिंग रिवॉल्यूशन नो इट्स डी
थर्ड ओके नेक्स्ट है ये 4 दिन की जिंदगी
में फ्लाइंग रेड की और डोंट एवं भाई
लेकिन कोई कोई रिलेट कर पानी हो सकता है
कोई रिलेटिव भी हो हो नहीं भी हो देखो
फाउंडर ग्रैंड टॉप प्रीवियसली
मैं कम कर सकता हूं क्या इनके बीच में कभी
कोई ट्वीट हुई है मैं उसको फाइंड आउट करने
की कोशिश करूंगा फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश
करूंगा
और लिविंग को
एनडीए
[संगीत]
करता है
तो हो सकता है
थैंक्स थैंक्स यह रिप्लाई इन्होंने को
रिप्लाई
मतलब
ये क्या चीज है अरे यार यही पे ओपन कर
दिया मैंने चलो
गुड़गांव के पास इनफॉरमेशन
अब बात करते हैं ट्रिक 5 की देखो आईटी बिल
टाइम
उसे कर सकते हैं वह कौन सी क्योंकि इसमें
क्या है बहुत कुछ आपस में उसे कर सकते हो
जो नेक्स्ट ट्रिक है आपकी देखो बात करते
हैं वो है आपकी फिल्ट्रेशन ट्रिक है
फिल्ट्रेशन ट्रिक है फिल्टर कैसे करना है
देखो मैं बताता हूं एक मिनट नेक्स्ट वीक
आपके आई है आपकी इलिटरेशन ट्रिक
अल्टर एक फिल्टर की ट्रिक आई है देखो
फिल्ट्रेशन करना है क्यों जरूरी है
फिल्ट्रेशन करना क्यों जरूरी है देखो आपने
अभी तक जितनी भी इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग की
होगी
जो अनवांटेड ए रही है बार-बार आप नहीं
चाहते की आपके सामने आए और ज्यादा फॉक्स
नहीं कर पे जिसकी वजह से बार-बार
कर सकते हो या मिनिमाइज कर सकते हो
आप ज्यादा फॉक्स कर सकते हो किसका उसे
करके आप इसका उसे करके फिल्टर तो मुझे
जस्ट सेकंड
ओके सॉरी पर डिस्टरबेंस तो अब बात करते
हैं की इसको हम कैसे करें फिल्टर में हम
क्या कर सकते हैं की ओनली पर्टिकुलर चीज
की बेसिक फील्डर कर सकते हैं फिल्टर पर
किसके ओनली इमेज के बेसिस पे इमेज के
बेसिस फिल्टर कर सकते हैं या दूसरा हम
किसके बेसिस पे कर सकते हैं
फिल्टर कर सकते हैं ओनली बेसिस ऑफ इसके
बेसिस पर वीडियो के बेसिस पर ओन्ली वीडियो
चाहिए
स्विमिंग के बेसिस पे हम क्या कर सकते हैं
फिल्टर कर सकते हैं किसी पर्टिकुलर यूजर
नाम को किसी के शब्द को अब देखिए आपको पता
है की फोटोस और वीडियो है अभी मैं क्या है
काफी कुछ इनफॉरमेशन आपको देखने को मिलती
है तो इसलिए क्या है की आप सबसे पहले क्या
करते हैं फोटो और हर एक उसमें पोस्ट में
बेसिकली क्या कहते हैं फोटोस या वीडियो ही
देते हैं बहुत कम रेट चांसेस होते हैं की
नॉर्मल कोई एक छोटे से कुछ शब्द में लिखी
हुई
पोस्टिंग पोस्ट क्या होती है किसी फोटोस
के साथ होंगे या वीडियो के साथ रहेगी
जिनके ऊपर ट्वीट होना चाहिए
कम्युनिकेट भी करते हैं एक दूसरे को अपने
विचार विमर्श क्या उसे पर जय करते हैं तो
अभी आपको पता है की
फालतू की इनफॉरमेशन हमारे सामने ए रही थी
अब अगर आई को फिल्टर अपडेट कर सकते हो
ट्विन टी ब्लू आई एन जी ट्विनिंग
क्या है
एग्जांपल ले लेट हूं इसी का यूजर नाम का
एग्जांपल ले लेट क्योंकि हमारे पास यही है
एक एग्जांपल कॉपी करता हूं अब इन्हीं का
ही मैं क्या है एग्जांपल लेट हूं
कंट्रोल भी करता हूं यह मेरा है इसके बाद
मुझे क्या फिल्टर करना ओनली
उसमें आपको देखने को मिले इमेज के अलावा
और भी कुछ आपको देखने को ना मिले अब मैं
क्या कर दिया अभी देखना मेरा जितना भी
आउटपुट रहेगा सब में इमेज देखने को मिलेगी
तब मैं आपको क्या है
देखिए उसमें क्या है बट क्या हुआ भाई
ओके
जी देखने को मिलेंगे इमेज
को क्या करना है
तो डॉ करके देखना हर एक चीज पर आपको देखने
जाके देखना है
ओके और
प्रोफाइल ग रही है लिविंग आगे जीरो वन
लिविंग ऑफ डी हा
वीडियो में चलते हैं
देखो वीडियो
मैंने क्या किया वीडियो
एस वीडियो
रिलेटेड ही देखने को मिलेगी अब देखिए इस
तरीके
उसे करके फिर आपको इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग कर
सकते हैं
मैंने क्या किया पेटीएम कंपनी के किसी भी
मेंबर को यहां पर ओनली रैंडम मैंने क्या
किया यहां पर टारगेट आपको परफॉर्म करके
दिखाए है आई एम सॉरी
देखते हुए इन फ्यूचर में उसके लिए सॉरी पर
डेट मैं किसी को रिवील नहीं कर रहा है
यहां पर तो इस तरीके से क्या किया
उसे करता हूं पहले इसको मैं यहां पर इसको
वीडियो दिखता हूं आपको परिस्को
पी
मतलब
कमेंट किया है या नहीं किया है तो ये थी
आपकी एक और ट्रिक फिल्ट्रेशन से रिलेटेड
ट्रिक अब आप सभी को पता है की एक और ट्रिक
के बड़े में बात करने वाले हैं जो है
लॉजिक ट्रिक होती है आप सभी को पता है की
अभी तक जितनी भी प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज
पड़ी है हर जगह पढ़ने आए हुए
लॉजिक में भी कौन सी दो शब्द सुनने को
मिलते हैं आपको सबको पता है कौन से दो
शब्द होते हैं लॉजिक में भी
नंबर
सिक्स में हम बात करते हैं
यहां पर मैं एक्सप्लेन करने वाला नहीं है
पर एग्जांपल
जब मैं फोन
किया मैंने यहां पर किया
इसका मतलब क्या है की मुझे रिजल्ट में वो
साड़ी पोस्ट चाहिए वो साड़ी पोस्ट चाहिए
जहां पर जिन पोस्ट में इन दोनों को क्या
किया हुआ है टैग किया हुआ है या इन दोनों
को क्या किया हुआ है मेंशन किया हुआ है इन
लोगों का यूजरनेम उसे किया गया है वो
साड़ी रिपोर्ट मतलब कौन सी इन दोनों का
दोनों का ही क्या होना चाहिए उसमें यूजर
नाम मेंशन होना चाहिए उन पोस्ट के अंदर उन
फोटोस के ऊपर उन दोनों को क्या करना चाहिए
ट्वीट्स होना चाहिए इन दोनों का ही होना
चाहिए
अगर कोई अकेला भी होगा
अगर मैंने यहां पर
क्या है
रिजल्ट
के साथ आपको आउटपुट देखने को मिलेगा
मैंने किया और डी रेट मैं यहां से उठाता
हूं क्योंकि
नेक्स्ट हम चलते हैं इसी के ऊपर ट्विटर
अकाउंट के ऊपर और यहां पर क्या किया मैंने
पेस्ट कर दिया
अभी देखो जहां पे इन दोनों को क्या किया
रिप्लाइंग तू इन्होंने इनको रिप्लाई किया
एन नोट रिप भाई पेटीएम तू अट्रैक्ट कस्टमर
वे डोंट वांट योर कैश बैक वे नीड ओनली
सर्विस लाइक वे चाट और
कस्टमर इन चीन ओ मी गॉड ओके कांग्रेस
तू यू मीत यू ऑन डी रहा चेयर्स
तो इसे भी आप क्या कर सकते हो ऐसे कुछ
इनके भी लेते हुए इनके भी इनके आपस में
क्या-क्या आप क्या कर सकते हो इनफॉरमेशन
भी आप कैसे इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग कर सकते हो
हो सकता है
तो यहां पर रिजल्ट आपके सामने और भी
ज्यादा देखने को मिलेगा
अभी क्या है इससे ज्यादा और आपको
देखने को रिजल्ट आपको देखने को मिलेगा तो
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग आपका कम है मेरा कम
सिर्फ आज है ट्रिक बताना आज हम आपको ट्रिक
बताऊंगा इनफॉरमेशन क्या देंगे आप लोगों को
करनी है ना की मुझे करनी है ओके क्योंकि
मुझे आई है इसलिए है ट्रेनिंग आप लोग भी
तो आप लोग सिख सकते हो ऐसे आप ट्रिक उसे
कर सकते हो तो ये है लॉजिक को उसे करना आप
कैसे लॉजिक को उसे कर सकते हो अब आपके हाथ
में है की इन लोग जिसको आप कैसे उसे करोगे
मैंने बता दिया की लोग इसको कैसे उसे किया
जाता है क्योंकि ये भी क्या कर सकते हैं
आपको काफी कुछ इनफॉरमेशन रेवल कर सकते हैं
किसी भी चीज के बड़े में यहां पर के शब्द
भी उसे कर सकते हो दो दो कीवर्ड्स को भी
आप कंपेयर कर सकते हो कुछ भी उसे कर सकते
हो जो नेक्स्ट ट्रिक होती है आपकी वो भी
काफी वो भी काफी इंपॉर्टेंट
देखो एक चीज है की अगर आपने इनफॉरमेशन
गैलरी की और इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग के दौरान
अगर आप ये पता कर करने में सक्सेसफुल हो
गया की आपका टारगेट कहां पर राहत है उसके
नियर बाई एरिया को आप सक्सेसफुली फाइंड
आउट करने में सक्सेस होंगे तो क्या है की
उसके बेसिस पे आप क्या कर सकते हो की
ट्विटर का उसे करके और भी ज्यादा
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग करने की कोशिश कर सकते
हो क्योंकि अगर आपके पास उसका आइडिया है
की वो कहां पर है एक नियर आइडिया है आपके
पास लोकेशन कहानी पर भी है तो आप क्या कर
सकते हो उसे एरिया में क्या आएगा सर
स्पेसिफिक एरिया में ट्वीट्स के बेसिस पे
भी क्या करता था आप इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग कर
सकते हो कंफर्म करने के लिए और यह काफी
हेल्प करती है क्योंकि देखो आपको क्या है
उसे करके देखो एक चीज है की इस ट्रिक का
उसे करके आप क्या कर सकते हो की उनके
पड़ोसी तक भी फाइंड आउट कर सकते हो उनके
फैमिली मेंबर्स और और भी जो लोग उसके
आसपास शहर होंगे देखो एक चीज है एक चीज
बताओ आप लोग ये आपको पता है की
अब कोई फेमस व्यक्ति कोई फेमस परसों है तो
क्या है की ठीक है उन्होंने कुछ टाइम पहले
अपना गांव शहर छोड़ दिया होगा लेकिन
फैमिली मेंबर से वहीं पर होंगे या फैमिली
मेंबर्स में कोई ना कोई ऐसे इंसान होते
जिनको काफी लगाव होता है अपने कम से वो
उधर ही रहते हैं तो वह क्या की अब देखो
फैमिली मेंबर्स को पता ही होता है फैमिली
मेंबर्स की सिक्योरिटी
नहीं पड़ता तो फैमिली मेंबर क्या है बड़ा
ही करने के लिए कुछ भी करने के लिए बताने
के लिए क्या है की कहानी ना कहानी
किसी किसी खास पड़ोसी उन्होंने क्या किया
मेरा लड़का ये करता हम ये करता है और इस
पोस्ट में है और ये पुरी कंपनी इसकी है
ऐसी कोई इनफॉरमेशन उन्होंने उनको बता दी
होगी
अब कहना क्या पड़ोसी को के पास इनफॉरमेशन
है वह तो आपको क्या लगता की पड़ोसी सिंपल
करने ग जाएगा और जब भी हर एक ट्वीट्स पर
क्या करेगा क्योंकि अब एक होता है ना की
अंदर की गांव वाली बात है या उसके शहर के
बाद है या उसके आसपास के एरिया का कोई
सक्सेसफुल इंसान है तो उसको क्या करेगा वो
हर चीज पर कमेंट करके उसको भी नोटिस करें
वो बताने की कोशिश करेगी मैं आपका गांव का
हूं मैं ये हूं सम टाइम्स के आपस में
ट्वीट करने की कोशिश करेगा तो ये साड़ी
इनफॉरमेशन अब यही तो वो स्टेप्स हो जाते
हैं कल के लिए एक्टर के लिए तो यही
इनफॉरमेशन
वही कम करता है इस टाइप की इनफॉरमेशन
क्या करता है वो 100 कर देता है क्योंकि
अब उसे एरिया में हो सकता है देखो अब यहां
पे इनकी अगर मैं देखा हूं प्रोफाइल देखिए
मैंने पर एग्जांपल
कहां पर है कहां पर र रहे हैं
अब इनकी प्रोफाइल
इनफॉरमेशन होगी कहा की ये हो सकते हैं पर
एग्जांपल अभी क्या की इंडिया का इनफॉरमेशन
क्या किया
[संगीत]
विधि उसे कर सकते हैं
अब यहां पे बहुत साड़ी पोस्ट आपको देखने
को मिलेगी बहुत साड़ी पोस्ट आपको देखने को
मिल रही है चलो मैं कम करता हूं यहां पर
देता हूं
@
इंडिया तो नहीं है भैया
यहां से क्या करता इनफॉरमेशन को उठाता हूं
और मैं क्या करूं
और पेस्ट कर देते
साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन इंडिया में कुछ अलग
डिस्टेंस के लिए उसे किया जाता है
क्योंकि अगर कोई अगर यह अगर कोई फॉरेनर
कंपनी है जिसको आप टारगेट कर रही हो और
एवं क्या है की वह कोई इंडिया से या किसी
स्पेसिफिक जगह से है तो आप क्या कर सकते
हो उसे जगह के बेसिस पे आप एनालिसिस कर
सकते हो
आप इसे ज्यादा वो कर नहीं का रहे हो तो
मैं कम करता हूं मैं
चलो मैं कम कर देता हूं इसको मैं
[संगीत]
कर देता हूं
लास्ट वन मंथ वे आर नोट अवेलेबल
शेखर और डी देखो यहां पर कुछ तो इनफॉरमेशन
देखो
कपिल चोपड़ा
अब ये इनफॉरमेशन दो काफी हमारे साथ हो
शक्ति है हेल्पफुल भी हो सकता है ज्यादा
लगता है देखो
देखिए देखिए हम क्या करें पर ट्वीट है
यहां पर
लाफिंग योर हार्ट आउट
हैदराबाद
कंट्रोल सी नेक्स्ट हम बात करते चलो हम
चलते ट्विटर पर ही अब मैं क्या कर देखो और
किया मैंने अभी बात करते हम
क्योंकि यह क्या है लोकेशन
है इनके बीच में जो कैट हो राखी है एक ही
कमेंट हमें मिली थी लेकिन वैसे इनकी बीच
में कोई ट्वीट है नहीं लेकिन दोस्तों हम
फाइंड आउट करने में सक्सेसफुल हो सकते हैं
पर कुछ चीजों को ऐसे कंफर्म करना पड़ेगा
सकता
है
एक नंबर आठ है जो हमारे कौन सी है
ना
ये पढ़ते पढ़ते काफी टाइम निकाल जाएगा
काफी टाइम काफी टाइम देखो अब एक और चीज
होती है
देखो कई बार क्या होता है की देखो कई बार
आप चाहते हो की जो कुछ कीवर्ड्स हैं कुछ
ऐसे लोगों के नाम हैं या कुछ ऐसे अकाउंट्स
है जो आप अपने
देखा नहीं चाहते आप चाहते हो की आपका जो
भी रिजल्ट आया है वो एक फॉक्स वे में
रिजल्ट आए एक एक्यूरेट रिजल्ट आए उसमें
कुछ भी
अनवांटेड चीज ना आए जो आपको लगता है तो
कैसे आप उसको एक्सक्लूड कर सकते हो किसी
चीज को आपको ग रहा है की मैं बार-बार जब
भी कुछ भी सर्चिंग कर रहा हूं किसी भी
टाइगर से रिलेटेड तो ये ऐसी चीज है जो
फालतू में ए रही है तो मैं इसको एक्सक्लूड
कैसे करूं तो उसके लिए भी आपके पास एक
ट्रिक होती है जो आप उसे करते हो
जो आप उसे करते हो दास जो हम उसे कर रहे
हैं
यार अभी टोटल 7 ट्रिक मैंने आपको बताई है
अभी तक देखो एक घंटा पास हो गया है
की देखो अब उसके बाद क्या है
थोड़ा सा तो मेहनत कर सकते हो वैसे तो
ट्रक अब बात करते हैं देखो दास और
यहां पर मैं आप क्या करोगे
लिख सकते हो आप कोई भी यूजर नाम जिसको आप
क्या करना चाहते हो एक्सप्लोर करना चाहते
हो वहां पर आप में आंसर कर सकते हो अब
क्योंकि आप ऐसा करके क्या बता रहे हो देखो
मैं कैसे कर सकता हूं पर एग्जांपल मैं
आपको एग्जांपल दिखाई देता हूं की आपके
स्क्रीन के ऊपर एग्जांपल ये है पर
एग्जांपल मेरे पास ये है इनका नाम है और
मैं सर्च कर रहा हूं इनके साथ और मैं क्या
चाहता हूं की
दास दास मतलब क्या है की मैंने हिफिन का
उसे किया उसके बाद में क्या हटाना चाहता
हूं पेटीएम
देखो यहां पर क्या है की मैं सर्च बाहर को
क्या बता रहा हूं अभी यहां पर कुछ आने लगा
वैसे मैं यहां पर क्या कर रहा हूं की आपको
जो विजय शेखर यूजर नाम है उसके बेसिस पे
आपको क्या करना है फाइंड आउट करना आपका
रिजल्ट लेकिन मैं क्या कर रहा हूं आपको
एक्सक्लूड करना है
जहां पर पेटीएम शब्द आपको देखने को मिलेगा
जहां जहां पर आपको पेटीएम शब्द देखने को
मिले
अब आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा ऐसे
ओके तो हां तो अभी मैं क्या बोल रहा हूं
यहां पर इनको ससुराल को यह बोल रहा हूं की
यह मेरा और मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं इस
यूजर के नाम पर आपको जितने भी पोस्ट देखने
को मिलती है जितनी भी ट्वीट्स आपको देखने
को मिल रही है इस यूजर नाम में की है वो
आप क्या करो मैं स्क्रीन पर शो कीजिए बट
क्या करना उसमें आपको पेटीएम की शब्द उसे
नहीं करना है उन पोस्ट में क्या है आपको
पेटीएम कीवर्ड उसे नहीं करना बड़े भाई
इन्होंने तो उसे किया है
ना
क्या बोलूं पेटीएम
यस नो इट्स वर्किंग नो इट्स वर्किंग
विजय शेखर मैं आप चाहता हूं की मैं अपने
जो सर्च बार उसको ये बोल रहा हूं की आते
डी रेट विजय शेखर बेसिक पे सारे के सारे
पोस्ट को आपको क्या करना है स्क्रीन पे शो
करना है लेकिन आपको एक चीज का ध्यान रखना
है की आपको जो पेटीएम की शब्द पेटीएम
कीवर्ड है वो उसे किसी भी पोस्ट में मेंशन
नहीं करना है उसे उसको क्या करना है
एक्सक्लूड करना है ये तो क्या है कीवर्ड
की बात का तो यहां पे यूजर नाम भी दे सकते
हो कीवर्ड का मतलब क्या है की कहानी पर भी
कीवर्ड मिले पेटीएम उसको क्या करेगा ये
देखिएगा नहीं उसको एक्सक्लूड कर देगा अगर
मैंने यहां पर ओनली
@ पेटीएम उसे किया है इसका मतलब क्या का
रहा है अब ये कीवर्ड को नहीं अब ये @
पेटीएम यूजर नाम को एस्क्लूइड कर रहा है
ना की ये शब्द को अब ये क्या है पेटीएम
यूजर नाम को क्या करना है
समझे मेरी बात क्या डिफरेंस है दोनों में
डिफरेंस ये था की पहले वाले विदाउट आते डी
रेट उसे किया तो ये क्या कर रहा था की
जहां जहां पर पेटीएम कीवर्ड मिल रहा था
उसको एक्सक्लूड कर रहा था अब सेकंड में
क्या है की जहां आप @ पेटीएम जो यूजर नाम
आपको देखने को मिल रहा है उसको क्या कर
रहा है अपने आप फुट में क्या कर रहा है
एक्सक्लूड कर रहा है अगर आप क्या चाहते हो
एक और चीज क्या कर सकते हो की अगर आप
चाहते हो किसी स्पेसिफिक चीज के बड़े में
आप सर्च करना चाहते हो पर एग्जांपल
स्पेसिफिक चीज के बड़े में अगर यहां पर
क्या है की आपने क्या किया की किसी के
शब्द को सर्च करना चाहते हो इसे उसे के
शब्द को आप क्या देखना चाहता हूं की उन
पोस्ट में वो कीबोर्ड होना चाहिए इस
यूजरनेम की लेकिन क्या है की आपको यह चीज
स्किप करनी है तो यहां पर क्या कर सकते
हैं आप उसे केवड़े का नाम दे सकते हो अभी
मेरे पास कोई कीवर्ड है नहीं थॉट्स वही
मैं आपको शो नहीं कर सकता तो मैं क्या लिख
सकता हूं की आप ऐसा भी कर सकते हो
स्पेसिफिक भी कर सकते हो एग्जांपल जैसे की
मैं वैसे बोलना हूं आपको यहां पर आप क्या
कर सकते हो की स्टार्टिंग में सबसे पहले
केवल
[संगीत]
और उसके बाद मैं क्या करूंगा
ओके तो आई बिल ट्री तू मी बेस्ट ओझा जी
आपके लिए रिपीट करने की कोशिश करूंगा
चलो फिर अब बात करते हैं ट्रिक नंबर नाइन
के बाद एक नंबर
एक नंबर नाइन की बात करते हैं देखो अब बात
करते हैं डिक्शनरी के बाद पर एग्जांपल अभी
आपने क्या किया की जब आप इनफॉरमेशन
गैदरिंग कर रहे थे और आपने क्या किया कुछ
चीज सस्पेक्ट की की आपने ये सब्सक्राइब
किया है की जो आपका टारगेट है उसने क्या
है की प्रीवियसली कुछ रंगीस में डेट रेंज
में कुछ
तारीखों पर उसमें क्या है किसी चीज के
बड़े में जिक्र किया है ये चीज के बड़े
में उन्होंने बात की है या कुछ चीजों के
बड़े में उन्होंने ट्वीट किया है किसी चीज
के ऊपर और आपको क्या है की वो एस्टीमेट
आइडिया है की इस डेट के आसपास उन्होंने
क्या किया है किस डेट के आसपास उन्होंने
वो ट्वीट किया होगा उसे पोस्ट के ऊपर तो
अगर आप डेट रेंज
करना चाहते हो या पोस्ट को फाइंड आउट करना
चाहते हो तो वह भी आप कर सकते हो बेसिकली
क्या है की आप एक पर्टिकुलर रेंज के अंदर
भी आप क्या करते हो बिट्स को फाइंड आउट कर
सकते हो लेकिन उसके लिए आपके पास एक वेयर
वेयर अबाउट का आइडिया होना चाहिए की हां
नेआर्बी की आप सस्पेक्ट होना चाहिए की
आपके टारगेट ने उसे टाइम में कुछ एसिडिटी
की होगी कई ऐसा टॉपिक चल रहा हो टिशु चल
रहा है कुछ ऐसा या कुछ उन्होंने लॉन्च
किया था जहां पर उन्होंने क्या अपने सारे
पार्टनर्स में मिल्क हो सकता है की
ट्वीट्स के थ्रू बात की हो काश किसी
कस्टमर ने बात की हो पॉर्न पार्टनर ने बात
की हो किसी ने कुछ भी बात की हो हो सकता
है की वहां पे कुछ आपको इनफॉरमेशन देखने
को मिल जाए तो वो मैं कैसे कर सकता हूं की
स्पेसिफिक मठ या स्पेसीफिकरे देखो इस
लास्ट क्लास लास्ट ली थोड़ी सी कुछ टाइम
पहले मैंने बताया था लिस्ट कमांड के बड़े
में लिस्ट लिस्ट
कमांड क्या करता है
उसके बेसिस पे आप क्या आउटपुट को शो कर
पता है लेकिन अभी क्या है
आप एक्जेक्टली आप क्या कर सकते हो वो पता
करने के लिए यहां पर
जा सकते हो इस ट्रिक में बेसिकली आपको
क्या है की ज्यादा आएगा ज्यादा चीज देखने
को इनफॉरमेशन कहते हैं देखने मिलेगी आपके
टारगेट के बड़े में क्योंकि देखो आपने जब
इनफॉरमेशन कहती थी सस्पेक्ट करते हो आपने
लगा की हां ये चीज भी इन्होंने ट्वीट किया
थे यार कुछ ऐसा इंटरेस्ट भी आपको लगा की
हां उसे टाइम पे इन्होंने किसी चीज में
इंटरेस्ट दिखाए था तो आप क्या कर सकते हो
की स्पेसिफिक रेंज के अंदर उसे चीज को
रेकों कर सकते हो क्या सच में इन्होंने
उसे टाइम पर उन पोस्टपेड किया था या नहीं
किया था तो चलो उसके लिए आप कैसे उसे कर
सकते हो उसके लिए आपके पास होता है एक तो
साइंस होता है साइंस डेट और स्पेसिफिक
साइंस होता है उसके अंदर क्या करते हो आप
डेट मेंशन करते हो आपका क्या करते हो फूल
डेट मेंशन करते हैं उसके बाद क्या करते
हैं
मतलब कब तक यहां पर डेट रेंज
होता है
अभी तक अभी तक
कर देता हूं तो यह क्या करेगा 2018
तक की इनफॉरमेशन को यहां पे साइड पोस्ट को
क्या कर रहा था ये आपको शो करके दे रहा है
देखो ओबीपीटी होने दी प्रूफ से का ओपन
काफी कुछ देखने को मिलेगा आपको देखो इनके
फोटो भी है कुछ है वो तो पहले से ही आपके
पास फोटो है अभी देखो और अगर आप क्या करना
है स्पेसिफिक रखना चाहते हो पर एग्जांपल
मैं चाहता हूं की नहीं मैं 20 जनवरी 2018
से लेकर 1 जनवरी अंटील
2019 तक की देखना चाहता हूं 2019 तक के तो
ठीक है 20 19
2018 दिसंबर की यह पोस्ट यह देखो ओन्ली
2001 साल की पोस्ट
भी आप क्या कर सकते हो किसी भी टारगेट के
बड़े में फाइंड आउट कर सकते हो रिप्लाई
में चलो
करता हूं
मतलब 2018
[संगीत]
वो देखो अब ये क्या @ ओवन कंपनी
वॅटीवर ये देखो ये क्या है
आपका कम और ढूंढना रिप्लाई तू डू यू हैव
एन कनेक्शन विद विजय शेखर
बातें कर रहे हैं तो मतलब क्या है
की आपको देखो क्या मिल सकता है की इस टाइम
रिलेशनशिप
के दौरान क्या है की बात कर रहे हो
फ्रेंड्स हो लेकिन क्या है की प्रेजेंट
टाइम में
काफी अच्छी बात हो शक्ति है
यह काफी अच्छी बात हो शक्ति है की हम उसका
बेनिफिट ले सकते क्योंकि देखो पहले वह
दोस्त थे
तो काफी अच्छी उसके बड़े में उसके पास
नॉलेज होगी इनफॉरमेशन होगी तो उसका भी हम
क्या करते हैं उसे कर सकते हैं इसको
टारगेट कर सकते हैं उसके बेसिस को क्या
किया
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग में मदद कर दे क्योंकि
हम उसको अपनी मैनिपुलेशन टेक्निक अपनी
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग उससे बात करके क्योंकि
वो उसका भी तो टारगेट हो गया ना तो पहले
दोस्त से अब दोस्त नहीं तो इस तरीके से हम
भी क्या कर सकते हैं और ज्यादा इनफॉरमेशन
गैदरिंग कर सकते हैं किसी पर्टिकुलर
टारगेट के बड़े में एक ये रेंज स्पेसिफिक
आपको पता चल गया होगा
अब बात करते हैं एक और चीज है इसी में
मुझे लगता है आईटी बिल टेक टाइम मुझे लगता
है की कल प्रोसीड करना चाहिए तो क्योंकि
अभी 720 हो गया और
क्या है की बच्ची हुई है अभी भी ट्रिक तो
नेक्स्ट क्लास में पढ़ने प्रोसेस करेंगे
हम इसी में तो चलो मैं आपको एक कम करता
हूं रिवीजन करवा देता हूं आपको रिवीजन
करवा देता हूं सभी का देखिए एक नंबर वन
क्या होती है ट्रिक नंबर वन में क्या
स्टार देखने को मिल रहा है स्टार का मतलब
एनीथिंग आपको एग्जांपल लेट हूं पर
एग्जांपल आपके पास क्या है की फूल एक इसी
भी टारगेट का यूजर नाम और सरनेम है और आप
क्या चाहते हो उसके बेसिस पे उसके रिलेटिव
या उसके नेटिव या उसके भाई वाइफ फादर किसी
को फाइंड आउट करना चाहते हो तो एक चीज
बताइए जब आप किसी चीज के बड़े में पता
करना चाहते हो तो आपको पता है की आपकी
फैमिली मेंबर्स भले ही आपने क्या किया
आपने अपना सरनेम उसे नहीं किया हो और आपने
क्या विदाउट आपने सरनेम की अपनी प्रोफाइल
उसे किया क्योंकि आप अवेयर
हो बट क्या-क्या आपके फैमिली मेंबर नहीं
होते तो आपके फैमिली मेंबर क्या करेंगे
उसे सरनेम का उसे करके क्या करेंगे अपनी
ट्विटर पर प्रोफाइल बनाएंगे तो हो सकता है
की इस चीज का उसे करके हम उसे सरनेम के
बेसिस पे उनके रिलेटिव उसके ब्रदर्स और
उसके वाइफ अगर चाइल्ड होंगे बच्चे होंगे
उनके भी बड़े में हम क्या कर सकते हैं
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग कर सकते हैं अब बात
करते हैं एक नंबर तू की तो ट्रिक नंबर तू
आपको देखने को मिल रही है लिस्ट ओके ये
मैंने गलत लिख दिया यहां पर ल आई एस टी
लिस्ट मतलब क्या है की अगर आपके पास कुछ
इंटेल है कुछ आपके पास है इनफॉरमेशन गैलरी
में कुछ ऐसा मिला है की आपको लगता है की
किसी स्पेसिफिक मठ में मठ ऑफ डी एयर किसी
स्पेसिफिक मठ में किसी स्पेसिफिक एयर में
उन्होंने क्या है की किसी ऐसे इवेंट पर
किसी ऐसे मुद्दे पर क्या किया उन्होंने
ट्वीट किया होगा और वहां पर क्या बाकी और
लोगों ने भी किया है
तो वह भी आप क्या कर सकते हो यहां से
कंफर्म कर सुकून क्या सच में किया है या
नहीं किया दूसरा क्या है की आप क्या कर
सकते हो की इवेंट्स को भी जा जा के फाइंड
आउट कर सकते हैं पर एग्जांपल अगर आपने
एग्जांपल लिया की आपका इंटरेस्ट है आपका
पर एग्जांपल आपका है इंटरेस्ट है
आपका इंटरेस्ट किसी चीज में मैं पर
एग्जांपल की आपको तो टारगेट है और टारगेट
का इंटरेस्ट है हर बार क्रिकेट जाके देखना
स्टेडियम में क्रिकेट देखना है और उसके
बाद
क्या करता है हैशटैग के साथ यहां पर दो
ट्रिक एक साथ कम करवा रहा हूं मैं आपको
ट्रिक नंबर थ्री ट्रिक नंबर तू तो हैशटैग
अब हैशटैग क्या कर रहा है हैशटैग क्रिकेट
उसके बाद लोकेशन के साथ क्या कर रहा है
स्टेडियम में अच्छी सी पिक और क्या करें
वो अपलोड कर दी अब उसके बाद वो उसके कंपनी
वालों ने उसके साइबर सिक्योरिटी इंजन है
उसको समझाया की सर ये ओपन
हो सकते हो लोग आपको टारगेट कर रहे हैं तो
उसमें क्या है उसके बाद क्या की वो ज्यादा
जरूरी है लेकिन हैशटैग उसके बाद क्या
ट्वीट करता है लेकिन फोटो सेल्फी लोकेशन
के साथ उन्होंने डालना बैंड कर दिया बट
क्या है की आपके पास आपको लगा की किसी
आपने इनफॉरमेशन गैलरी कर्ज आपके सामने कोई
ऐसी चाट आई ऐसी ट्वीट आई ऐसी पोस्ट है
जहां पर उन्होंने क्या है की खुद का भी
फोटो डाला होगा किसी एयर में इसी आ मठ में
आपको वह थोड़ा सा आइडिया है तो आप क्या कर
सकते हो की लिस्ट ट्रिक का उसे करके साथ
में आपके पास क्या है
# है इन दोनों को कंबाइन करके आप क्या कर
सकते हो उसे स्पेसिफिक इनफॉरमेशन तक पहुंच
सकते हो इसका मतलब आप कंफर्म कर सकते हो
ओके मैं टारगेट को क्रिकेट देखना पसंद है
और वह जाता दी है लेकिन सिक्योरिटी
अवेयरनेस की वजह से उसने की आपने लाइव
लोकेशन डालनी बैंड कर दी तो ओके लेकिन अभी
भी पसंद है ओके एक चीज कंफर्म कर पे ट्रिक
नंबर फोर की बात करता हूं अब ट्रिक नंबर
पर में क्या है की आपने जब भी इनफॉरमेशन
गैदरिंग की अब आपने जब आप पोस्ट पढ़ रहे
थे तो पोस्ट पढ़ने वक्त आपने क्या किया एक
लिंक बना लिया इनफॉरमेशन का की हां यह
इसका दोस्त हो सकता है या पार्टनर हो सकता
है दूसरे अदर कंपनी के या ये आपस में
इन्वेस्ट करता था बी पार्टनर्स है है या
कोई यह क्या है की हाय प्रोफाइल इंजीनियर
है जो इनकी कंपनी में कम करता है तो है
कस्टमर कस्टमर तो होगा नहीं कस्टमर के साथ
तो कभी को फाउंड होता है लेकिन एम्पलाई के
साथ नहीं लेकिन हाय प्रोफाइल एंपलॉयर के
साथ हो सकता है तो अब वो क्या है आपस में
दोस्त है यह क्या है की हो सकता है कोई
हाय प्रोफाइल अपा है और वो उनका दोस्त है
क्योंकि रिकमेंडेशन हो गई होगी तो अब वो
आपके पास इनफॉरमेशन है लेकिन अब आप क्या
कंफर्म करना चाहते हैं की वह आपस में चाट
कर भी रहे नहीं की तो उसके बेसिक पर क्या
कर सकते हो की आपके पास एक ट्रिक होती है
फ्रॉम o2 मतलब क्या फॉर्म में आपने क्या
किया की जो सीईओ है @ जो आपके एक तमाशा
विजय शेखर है और दूसरी जगह उनके फ्रेंड का
नाम मैंने मेंशन किया मैं ये देखना चाहता
क्या ट्वीट के थ्रू इनके बीच में
कम्युनिकेशन हुआ है ये क्या करेगा फ्रॉम
तू मतलब क्या करेगी फॉर्म से यूजर नाम वन
से लेकर यूजर नाम वन तू मतलब
शेखर साहब से लेकर उसके जो फ्रेंड के बीच
में अगर कोई ट्वीट हुआ होगा इन्होंने उसके
साथ कुछ रिप्लाई किया होगा ट्वीट किया
होगा तो यहां से मैं कंफर्म कर रहा हूं की
हां ये कंपनी वीडियो अच्छे फ्रेंड भी है
फिर उसके बाद रिवर्स कर रहा हूं की ओके
जिनका फ्रेंड है और इनके विजय शेखर साहब
के बीच में कुछ कम्युनिकेट हुआ है या नहीं
हुआ है ओके चलो ये चीज कंफर्म कर ली उसके
बाद क्या की इस तरीके से आप क्या कर सकते
हो फ्रॉम o2 को उसे कर सकते हो उनके बीच
के कम्युनिकेशन को देखने के लिए और इससे
आपको एक और चीज हेल्पफुल मिल शक्ति है
क्या हेल्प मिल शक्ति है की जब आप क्या कर
रहे थे की इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग कर रहे थे तो
आपको
इनफॉरमेशन कैसे के बाद आपको क्या मिला
यूजरनेम और मिल गया फ्रेंड मिल गए और हो
सकता है की यह ऐसे क्लोज फ्रेंड हो या
पार्टनर्स हो अगर पार्टनर्स के बीच में
आपने क्या कम्युनिकेशन को चेक किया
कम्युनिकेशन को इस ट्रिक का उसे करके आपने
फाइंड आउट किया तो आपको ऐसा हॉट इशू मिला
किसी प्रोजेक्ट से रिलेटेड या किसी पॉलिसी
रिलेटेड कुछ ऐसा वह पे इनफॉरमेशन मिली जो
आपको आपके लिए काफी यूजफुल थी और उसे
इनफॉरमेशन आपने नोट डॉ करके रख दिया
क्योंकि बाद में जब आप हैकिंग परफॉर्म
करेंगे या आप एक्सप्लोइटेशन परफॉर्म
करेंगे वो परफॉर्म करने के लिए आपको क्या
है बहुत बड़ा हैकिंग से बने में क्या है
यह साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन आपको हेल्प करेंगे तो
फ्रॉम मोटू ऐसे उसे कर सकते हो ट्रिक नंबर
फाइव की बात करता हूं अभी तक क्या कर सकते
हैं आप रैंडम क्या यूजरनेम उसे कर रहे थे
या आप क्या कर रहे थे हैशटैग उसे कर रहे
थे और उसके बेसिस पे आपको क्या तो वीडियो
भी ए रही थी इमेज भी ए रही थी और लाइव भी
ए रहा था सब कुछ क्या मिक्स हो गया था
आपका जो आउटपुट था उपार्जन हो रहा था अब
आप क्या कर रहे होते नहीं मैं कम करता हूं
पहले मैं इमेज देखा हूं और फिर उसके बाद
ओनली वीडियो देखा हूं उसके बाद ओनली लाइव
पेरिस्कोप है लाइव इमेज देखना चाहता हूं
मतलब लाइव के ऊपर इन्होंने कभी ट्वीट किया
नहीं किया तो ओनली क्या कर सकता हूं मैं
फिल्टर कीवर्ड का उसे करके फिल्टर की जो
सॉरी फिल्टर जो ट्रिक है इसका उसे करके
मैं कैसा हूं पहले इमेज की जितना भी आप जो
प्रिंट होगा ट्विटर के पेज पर सर्च के
थ्रू और आगे क्या आपको कोई भी यूजर नाम
उसे कर सकता हूं तो उसके बेस में क्या
ओनली इमेज ही शो होगी उसकी रिजल्ट में और
उसे यूजरनेम के लिए थोड़ी आगे में इसके
आगे क्या क्या यूजर नाम उसे कर सकता हूं
यूजरनेम कोई भी हो सकता है कोई हैशटैग भी
उसे कर सकता हूं कोई कीबोर्ड भी सकता हूं
और ओनली इमेज ओनली इमेज आएंगे अगर ओनली
वीडियो देखना चाहता हूं तो ओनली वीडियो के
बेसिक फिल्टर करो क्योंकि बेसिकली मेरा
यहां मोटो क्या है की मैं मैं अनवांटेड
चीजों को थोड़ा क्या कर रहा हूं कम करना
चाहता हूं और मैं अपने आउटपुट को नैरो डॉ
करना चाहता हूं क्योंकि ये ट्रिक सिर्फ
हैकर्स के पास होती हैं ये ट्रिक किसी
नॉर्मल इंसान को नहीं पता नॉर्मल इंसान को
ऐसी चीज परफॉर्म नहीं करने आई उसे नैरो डॉ
से कोई मतलब भी नहीं होता क्योंकि वो बस
ट्विटर को उसे करने के लिए उसे नहीं पता
लेकिन हमें हैकर्स के लिए काफी इनफॉरमेशन
क्योंकि हम क्या करना है हमें एक छोटी सी
भी चीज हमने छोड़ने वाले छोटी सी भी चीज
नहीं होने वाली क्योंकि हम किसी भी चीज के
बड़े में ओपन सोशल इंटेलिजेंस जब करते हैं
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग करते हैं तो हम क्या है
15 दिन 10 दिन मीना बजाते हैं किसी भी
टारगेट के ऊपर उसके बड़े में इनफॉरमेशन
गैदरिंग करने के लिए अगर आपका टारगेट बहुत
बड़ा है तो दिन रात आप मीना स्पेंड करते
हैं उसे इनफॉरमेशन को गदर करने के लिए
उसको लिंक करने के लिए तो उसके लिए अभी
मीना को क्या नाम है पर ट्रिक भी होगी तभी
तो हम एक्यूरेट इनफॉरमेशन कर पाएंगे और ये
एक यूनिट इनफॉरमेशन हम तभी यहां पर कर
पाएंगे फिर ऐसे ट्रिक हमारे पास होगी तो
फटाफट तो ठीक है मेरे पास एक तरफ आइडिया
मिल गया मैंने एक नायक डिजाइन किया है की
ओके ये इस टाइप के इनफॉरमेशन ये साड़ी है
अब मैं इनको लिंक कैसे करूंगा इनके बीच
में लिंक कैसे ढूंढ लूंगा मैं और कैसे मैं
स्पेसिफिक डेट के भी हूं जा सकता हूं
स्पेसिफिक डेट पर मैं कैसे ढूंढ सकता हूं
तो ये साड़ी चीज हम ट्रिक की हेल्प से ही
कर सकते हैं एडरवाइज आप एक-एक चीज को सर्च
के थ्रू ए ट्रेडिशनल मेथड के थ्रू बैठोगे
तो आप नहीं कर सकते तो इस तरीके से आप
फिल्टर के बेसिस पे ए गया अपने रिजल्ट कर
सकते हैं नेक्स्ट देखो चीज होती है जो
आपको पता है ट्रिक नंबर सिक्स लॉजिक
अब क्या है की लॉजिक भी काफी हेल्पफुल
होते हर जगह एक तो प्रिंटर के थ्रू आप
फिल्टर कर सकते हो उसके बाद क्या आपके पास
बहुत सही यूजेस का नाम है बहुत सारे
क्योंकि आपको पता है की जब आपने लाइनेक्स
पढ़ा था लाइनेक्स में क्या करते हो आप और
और का उसे कर सकते हो और कांबिनेशन में
उसे करोगे तो उतना ही आपको अच्छा आउटपुट
मिलता थी लेकिन इसमें उसे कर सकते हो अगर
आपके पास दो यूजर्स हैं आप वो और आप
कंफर्म है की ये जो है पार्टनर्स है या
एंपलॉयर्स है या फैमिली मेंबर्स है तो
फैमिली मेंबर्स का तो इसमें रोल आता नहीं
लॉजिक में लॉजिक में आता है पार्टनर्स का
या हो सकता है कोको है तो अब मैंने क्या
कर दिया मैंने और लॉजिकल उसे किया
एंड्रोलॉजी को उसे करके मैं ये कंफर्म
करना चाहता हूं की मुझे वो साड़ी पोस्ट या
ट्वीट मेंशन करते हैं जहां पर इन दोनों ने
क्या किया होगा
इन दोनों को मेंशन किया गया है मतलब इन
दोनों मेंशन किया मतलब क्या है की इनके
बीच में कुछ ना कुछ तो रिलेशन है ही कहानी
ना कहानी आपको कुछ ऐसी इनफॉरमेशन लीकेज
मिलेगी जहां पर इनके बड़े में कुछ
रिलेशनशिप आपको प्रूफ कर दें कुछ आपको
लिंक करने के लिए हेल्प कर दें और का मतलब
क्या है और मैं क्या करूं यहां पर तीन
सीनेटर के टाइप से इनफॉरमेशन मिलेगी एक तो
यूजर नाम वन तू जी पोस्ट में हो या अकेला
यूजर वन हो या ओनली यूजर तू उसे पोस्ट में
हो एक नंबर से आते हैं एक नंबर सेवन की
बात आई है की अगर आप को आपके टारगेट ने
कहानी पर एक्सपोज किया होगा आपकी इसको
अपनी लोकेशन को खुद की लोकेशन को क्या
किया हुआ एक्सपोज किया होगा तो अब जब उसने
क्या किया खुद की लोकेशन को एक्सपोज कर
दिया तो ठीक है उसने क्या किया है इंडिया
तो बहुत बड़ा है
इंडियन कंपनी अगर ये फोन कंपनी होती
कहानी फोन कंपनी में अभी क्या इन्होंने
क्या इंडिया कर दिया क्या यह स्मार्ट है
इंडिया में से निकाल दिया अब इससे पहले
देखो अब मैंने कुछ देखा था की इसे पहले एक
इनफॉरमेशन मिली थी ये रही कहां गई वो
इनफॉरमेशन है इससे नीचे यह भी कपिल चोपड़ा
लिविंग लेजर कौन थे जनरल जिन्होंने
गुड़गांव पोस्ट करके मेंशन किया था
उन्होंने क्या स्पेसिफिक जगह को मेंशन कर
दिया इंडिया में गुड़गांव को मेंशन कर
दिया तो मुझे क्या करना मेरे पास एक
आइडिया की नियर गुड़गांव मुझे क्या करना
है की मेरे पास एक यूजरनेम है ये मेरे पास
है हैशटैग है और मुझे इतना पता है की
हैशटैग क्या है की अब क्योंकि पर्टिकुलर
पोस्ट से निकाला है आपके टारगेट कंपनी से
है तो आप क्या है आपको आइडिया आया की आपके
पास एक लोकेशन गुड़गांव तो आपने क्या कहते
हैं नियर और भी दिन का उसे कर लिया की
नियर गुड़गांव और गुड़गांव का एरिया आपने
क्या किया मेंशन किया और वहां पर क्या
किया आपने एक
पेरीमीटर बना दिया सर्किल मतलब आपको क्या
करना है की गुड़गांव में क्या विदीन उसकी
5 किलोमीटर है मतलब की पूरा-पूरा एक एरिया
है पर एग्जांपल मैं आपको एग्जांपल के थ्रू
अगर मैं दिखता हूं चलो ये रहा देखो अगर
मैं आपको एग्जांपल की थ्रू जाता भी हो तो
ये रहा देखो मैं गूगल मैप है तो ये रहा
गूगल मैप की बात करता हूं और ये ओके जैसे
की हां अब मैं बात करता हूं की जैसे की
चलो मैं इसकी बात करता हूं की चलो यहां पे
एग्जांपल न्यू दिल्ली लिया अब न्यू दिल्ली
किसी ने मेंशन कर दिया तो मैं क्या करता
हूं न्यू दिल्ली तो मेरा ठीक है टारगेट है
तो मैं इसके आसपास मैंने क्या कर दिया
फाइव किलोमीटर बोला की न्यू दिल्ली के 5
किलोमीटर की रेंज में जितने भी ट्वीट्स
हुए हैं इस पर्टिकुलर यूजर नाम
इस नाम के लिए या पर्टिकुलर हैशटैग के साथ
उसको उन्हें को क्या का रही है रेंज
स्पेसिफिक की अगर आपको शो करें तो इससे
क्या है की आप ज्यादा डर दो कर पाओगे ओके
मतलब क्योंकि उनको कोई जानता होगा या तो
उनके कस्टमर ऐसे केसेस में आपको खून मिल
सकते हैं आम सेंस की बात है जब आपने नियर
की बात करें
यहां पर कौन मिल सकते हैं हमें या तो उनके
कस्टमर मिलेंगे
फालतू में किसी को ट्वीट करने में तो
इंटरेस्ट होता नहीं है तो इसलिए यहां पर
ये वो चीज मिलने की ज्यादा संभावना उससे
क्या की वो इसकी लोकेशन भी कंफर्म कर पाते
हैं और दूसरा क्या इसके जो इनके यूजरनेम
है जो इनके फ्रेंड्स हैं क्लोज फ्रेंड है
या पार्टनर्स है रिलेटिव इधर भी मिल सकते
हैं यहां पे मिलने की चांसेस है इनफॉरमेशन
गैदरिंग में ये है नियर विदीन का कमल अब
बात करें ट्रिक नंबर आते ट्रिक नंबर आते
के बाद करता हूं अब आप मैंने क्या बताया
की आप अपने आउटपुट कौर भी नायरा डॉ करना
चाहते हैं क्योंकि जब आप बार-बार
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग कर रहे हैं तो कुछ ऐसे
अनवांटेड ये रिलेटिव चीज आपको देखने को
मिल रहे हैं आपको लगता है की ये हर बार
इसमें कुछ इनफॉरमेशन है ही नहीं है इसमें
कोई इनफॉरमेशन ही नहीं है तो फिर क्या
करोगे तो उसमें क्या करोगे आप आपको हर बार
उसे एक्सक्लूड करना है की वो मुझे रिजल्ट
मिलन चाहिए की मुझे इन के शब्द को इन
हैशटैग को या इन यूजर्स नाम को मैं
एस्क्लूइड करना चाहता हूं तो यहां पर वो
कम है
एक्सक्लूड करना चाहते की किसी चीज को तो
आप क्या है उसके साथ हिफिन उसे करना और
हिफिन को विदाउट जितने भी फिल्टर आप उसे
करते हो सबके साथ आपको क्या करना है
विदाउट स्पेस उसे करना है सबके साथ तो उसे
यहां पर कोई भी कीबोर्ड उसे नहीं आप मेंशन
कर सकते हो एग्जांपल मैंने दिया है यहां
पर कीवर्ड किया है लिया की मैं क्या जाता
हूं एक कीवर्ड्स स्पेसिफिक मत सर्च करना
चाहता हूं वो भी इस यूजरनेम के लिए और
लेकिन मैं एक्सप्लोडिंग करना चाहता हूं इन
कीवर्ड्स को इन यूजरनेम को उसमें एक्स-रेड
करना था अब ट्रिक नंबर नाइन की बात करता
हूं ट्रिक नंबर नाइन में साइंस और अंटील
की बात है अब ट्रिक नंबर नाइन अपने आप में
क्लियर मेंशन है की आप डेट रेंज स्पेसिफिक
चीज के बड़े में पता करना था क्योंकि आपके
पास एक इंटेल है एक इनफॉरमेशन है की
इंटेल और इनफॉरमेशन किसके बेसिस पर आपके
पास जो इंटेल है इनफॉरमेशन आपके पास वो
इनफॉरमेशन है की हां इस डेट के दौरान या
इस एयर के दौरान उन्होंने किसी चीज ट्वीट
किया था की इस चीज को कम किया था तो वहां
पर क्या हो सकता है की पार्टनर्स हो इनके
कलीग एम्पलाई हो तो वो साड़ी चीज इसके
बेसिस पे आप फाइंड आउट कर सकते हो मतलब इन
हर एक ट्रिक को उसे करके कर सकते हो की
अलग-अलग इनफॉरमेशन कर सकते हो काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग इनफॉरमेशन आपको देखने को मिल
शक्ति है
यस नो बता दीजिए उसके बाद क्लास को एड
करते हैं कल कंटिन्यू करते हैं
ओके तो हमसे कम करते हैं सचिन को आज के
लिए एड करते हैं और
क्या करते हैं
एडरवाइज आपको क्या है फिर परसों ही होगा
तो हम निकाल कर
आपको अगर सेशन होगा तो आपके पास क्या है
आपको ग्रुप में इनफॉरमेशन मिल जाएगी कल
आपका सेशन है या नहीं है ओके चलो